تقول الشرطة أن هذا الفيديو بالغ
الأهمية للتحقيق،
ويأملون أن
يعرف شخص ما هوية هذين الشخصين في هذا
الفيديو، لذا دعوني أصف لكم الأمر
وما الذي تتدخل فيه الشرطة حقًا،
هناك مركبتان في هذا الفيديو  الفيديو الأول
هو شاحنة صغيرة من طراز تشيفي سيلفرادو
والآخر هو سيارة كيا أوبتيما الفضية وما
تراه في هذا الفيديو هو أن
هاتين المركبتين تقفان جنبًا إلى جنب،
ويبدو أن سائق تلك الشاحنة الصغيرة وسائق كيا أوبتيموس
يتفاعلان و  يبدو أن
سائق الشاحنة الصغيرة قام
بمسح جانب سيارة كيا أوبتيما، وليس من
الواضح بالضبط ما يفعلونه ولكن
هذا ما تقوم الشرطة بإدخاله
الآن، الجدول الزمني وموقع
هذا الفيديو واضح تمامًا  أمر بالغ الأهمية ولهذا
السبب تم التقاط مقطع الفيديو بالقرب من المكان الذي
تم العثور فيه على الجثث، تقول الشرطة
إنهم يعتقدون أن الجثث كانت في
ذلك الموقع لبضعة أيام ثم
كذلك أه هذا الفيديو أه يظهر سيارة كيا
أوبتيما التي تعتقد الشرطة أنها مملوكة
لماثيو جارا  تقول شرطة الضحية البالغة من العمر 22 عامًا
إن جارا توفي متأثرًا
بجراحه في الرأس وما
يعنيه ذلك هو أنهم يعتقدون أن السلاح الناري
تم وضعه مباشرة على رأس ماثيو جي
عندما قُتل وسأل عما إذا
كانت هذه جريمة قتل انتحارية أم لا.  تقول الشرطة
أن هذا ممكن ولكن في هذه المرحلة
يبدو من غير المرجح أن تقوم الشرطة أيضًا
بتمشيط المزيد من مقاطع فيديو المراقبة
بالإضافة إلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لمحاولة
معرفة من قتل هذين الشخصين ولماذا
ومتى نعود إلى الخط الزمني
هنا، هذا جزء  ما يجعل هذه القضية
محيرة حقًا للشرطة، على سبيل
المثال، يوم 22 ديسمبر هو اليوم الأخير
الذي تقول فيه الشرطة إن أي شخص سمع من
سافانا سو كانت تبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا فقط
وكانت حاملاً في شهرها التاسع وفي
23 ديسمبر فاتتها موعد مهم
مع طبيبة النساء والتوليد  كان من المفترض أن يتم تحريضها على
الولادة -
بدلاً من ذلك - لكنها فاتتها هذا
الموعد وأخبرت عائلتها
الشرطة أنها كانت مفقودة في
26 ديسمبر، وذلك عندما عثرت الشرطة على جثتي
ماثيو جارا البالغ من العمر 22 عامًا و
18 عامًا  - سافانا سو القديمة، يتم الآن
التحقيق في هذه القضية باعتبارها قضية قتل كابال
مرة أخرى، وتحث شرطة سان أنطونيو
الجمهور على التقدم بأي
معلومات